warning this video contains cold B ah
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to a brand new cold Geass video
and in this video we will be talking
about blue Geass there are still many
mysteries left to be solved within the
world of Code Geass and one of the
biggest ones is what exactly is blue
Geass and why is it different from all
other types of us which are always
reddish either darker red or lighter red
but generally always substrate over red
I think that I may have finally solved
the mystery of blue Geass and what makes
it different from regular types of the
US and I think that this might actually
have some important consequences for
season 3 don't forget that here animail
for one of your number one source for
all the latest theories and news for
code geass season 3 and a bunch of other
animes so be sure to subscribe for more
and click that notification bell so you
can be the first to know every time we
learn something new now the very first
time that we see any type of Geass
manifest as blue is when Jeremiah
Gottwald gets his Geass canceler in the
original code geass series and actually
at first I didn't think much of this
because I thought that his Geass was
only different only a different color
because it was artificial it was created
artificially so I thought that was why
it was blue rather than red however in
the official code geass OVA called a key
to the Exile a new character is
introduced by the name of layla mal call
or Leila Briscoe who actually has blue
gear Inaki to the Exile we learned that
layla actually got her power from c2 she
got her deals from c2 so we know for
sure that it is not artificial and we
also learned that c2 get Leila an
interesting option to her contract
she tells her that she her Geass will be
activated only if Leila chooses to use
it sometimes before reaching full
adulthood but if she chooses not to use
it
the Geass power would not be activated
which is kind of unique in the final
episode of the OVA we ultimately see
Layla's power finally manifesting itself
and the interesting thing about it of
course is that her Geass is blue now the
exact details about how Layla's Geass
power works are
known to us and there even unknown to
Leila herself however I believe that I
finally figured out how her he has power
works and why exactly it is blue
big thanks to know digit phantom age the
rats and Emperor Lelouch VI Britannia
not the real one but the guy on our
discord for giving me some really good
feedback on my series thank you guys and
if you want to join our discord server
and help with future series and future
videos the link is in the description so
the big question is how does Layla's
Geass power actually work and why is it
blue in episode 3 of a key to the exiled
on elderly gypsy lady tells layla that
the curse or Geass that c2 gave her as a
child has the power to help her protect
those she loves and cares about such as
a keto for example for whom she develops
feelings throughout the show even though
layla herself does not know how her
Geass power actually works so Layla's
Geass power is understood to be the
power to protect those she loves and
cares about in some way and this is
almost the exact opposite of the power
of Shin Hyuga Chang who is the main
villain of the series and who deals
power is to force those he cares about
and love to kill themselves or to kill
someone else and this is because he
believes that life is a curse life is
suffering and that those he loves are
better off dead than continuing on to
live in this world now my theory is that
the reason Layla's power is different
the reason it manifests as blue is
because her Geass is completely selfless
she only wants to help others though she
cares about she only wants others to be
happy her Diaz power does not benefit
her or give her power in any direct way
if you think back to Jeremiah Gottwald
or Lord orange the effect of his Geass
is very similar his Geass canceller does
not make him more powerful or benefit
him in any way all it does is it has an
effect on other people and he believes
that the effect is to help other people
by disarming dangerous Geass users so
what orange does when he allows the
Geass order to experiment
in order to create the artificial Diaz
is he essentially sacrifices his body in
the name of his loyalty in the name of
others because he believes that he is
serving a higher purpose and a higher
good at the expense of his own body now
of course oranges Geass power is
artificial and it is a Geass Chancellor
it essentially inverts the power of the
Geass that others use so that is why the
symbol of Geass on his eye is actually
upside down it is inverted but could it
be that for those individuals who
receive Geass but their wish their
greatest wish is completely selfless
they don't want any power for themselves
they only want to help others that
they're the ones whose Geass manifest as
blue don't forget that the Geass power
of each individual Geass user is catered
to their own motivations their own
ambitions and wishes so for the red
Geass users we know that they are
motivated by power or personal benefit
so for C 2 she wants to be loved by
others for Lelouch he wants to have
control over others so that he can
achieve his political goal we might say
that his overall ambition is a good one
however he of course uses very much
self-interested tactics and motivations
in order to get to where he wants to be
to create a better world we also know
that mal can read minds because he
doesn't want to be lonely so he knows
how to read the minds of other people
and we know that Charles who wants to
reshape the world to his own liking can
rewrite the memories of other people and
so on I believe that this selfless
aspect of Blue Geass is the reason why
the mysterious being with code that
appears in our key to the Exile the
female that identifies herself as a
guardian of space-time and a
representation of collective
consciousness says to Leila that while
she initially thought that humans were
not worthy of having Geass and that
Geass should be taken away from them
even at the price of humanity going
extinct now this being believed because
of Leila that Leila is unique and that
she might change her mind about humanity
because of Leila's unique Ghia I believe
that Leila proves herself to be worthy
of Jia in the eyes of this mysterious
being because her motivations are
selfless
she is not after power she does not
create power for herself episode 5 of
okeechobee exile the final episode is
really important and it tells us a lot
about Leila's Geass this episode which
is titled to the beloved one shows us
that Leila's Geass seems to be actually
capable of reshaping the physical world
in order to allow her to save those she
loves if we look at around the 32 minute
mark of episode 5 we see that
Akito and his brother shin their minds
seem to briefly merge together into a
single consciousness and this is
presumably due to the effect that shins
Geass power had had on his brother as a
child it seems to this power seems to
linger with akuto just like Lelouch is
command to live seems to linger with
Suzaku the scientists were at this time
monitoring Iquitos brainwaves conclude
that human thoughts are able to actually
interfere with the real world MELAS
friend who is a scientist actually said
perhaps our universe shaped itself
according to its beholders observation
she says that the entanglement of
multiple people's minds gives birth to
an overwhelming observer or a sentient
creature that is a representation of
this collective consciousness such a
being could go beyond the scope of space
and time and even the past is not a
certainty anymore what's more we can
create the whole universe on new and
around the 36 minute mark in our kitto
just as laila friends are killed in an
attack Layla's Geass is finally
activated and it shines blue she calls
out the names of her friends she sees a
vision of her parents who are dead she
sees a vision of a kitto being in danger
and suddenly she finds herself back in
the same room but in a moment in time
where her friends had not been attacked
yes and they are actually still alive
and at this point while time appears to
be frozen a mysterious being with code
appears to Leila and tells Leila that
she is the guardian of space-time in a
representation of collective
consciousness
she says that the collective
consciousness intervenes in the
evolution of the universe
she says that humans crave power and
only want to have their wishes granted
but Leila's power is somehow unique
Leila says that what she is wishing for
is the happiness of everyone so again
her power is helpless the being then
goes on to say that the power Leila
possesses is a fragment of Geass and
that people should not be able to
possess the full extent of Geass power
so the collective consciousness wants to
take this power back from human she
thought this being thought of humans as
a defective form of life that should not
have any contact with yeeow she would
have preferred that humans become
extinct rather than to have this power
however she tells Leila the following
but you may be the one who will disprove
my opinion if only she could stop the
man who is cursed by his Geass power
meaning Shinji bashang and again just
emphasizes the concept that Leila's
power is the opposite of Shean and that
she must be the one to stop him
after this Leila returns to the point
before her friend died and she succeeds
in stopping the attack that was supposed
to kill them so what happened here was
Leila seeing her friend died just a
vivid example of precognition or did her
Geass actually turned back time in order
to save those she loved when at the very
end of this episode Leila's power
activates again just as Shin is about to
kill Akiko Shin sees those who love
Akito projected in front of him as
visions preventing him from killing
akuto so Leila's Geass power seems to
also give her a special mental
connection
with those that she cares for as Shin is
dying Layla's Geass acts through Akiko
to allow him and Shin to share a
heartwarming vision of their childhood
in the manga off of the reflection we
see a brief description of Leila's power
and this description reads the following
there was another that wanted to be able
to keep things from going the way they
were meaning Leila the other wanted to
change the direction of where things
were going this seems to be saying that
when someone close to her is in danger
Leila can change reality itself to save
them she was recognized by the
collective consciousness as unique
because her greatest wish and Geass
power is selfless she wants only to help
others and to save the one she loves
she doesn't want power or benefits for
herself
I want to thank phantom age from our
discord server for translating this
quote from the Portuguese because we
could not find an online version of the
English manga but he was able to find
the Portuguese one thanks a lot bro I
feel that this being this collective
consciousness after watching for
centuries humans abuse Geass power only
because they crave more power and
benefit for themselves was amazed to
finally find a human like Layla who only
wanted to help others who did not want
to abuse Geass power in order to gain
more things for herself and this
selflessness is what I believe
distinguishes Layla's Geass from others
this selflessness is what makes her
Geass manifest as blue another unique
thing about Layla's power is that it
seems to challenge our usual
understanding of Geass to be a strictly
mental power because she seems capable
of altering physical reality when she
seems to turn back time in order to
protect those she loved however this is
not the only example of Geass altering
physical reality in the koteas manga Ren
the darkness a character called Emperor
- has a Geass power which seemingly
allows them to alter reality by allowing
him to turn individuals like Thalia into
a nightmare although the details on how
exactly this power works are very vague
it seems to go hand in hand with this
concept of the mind actually reshaping
the physical world so here are my
biggest takeaways from all of this I
believe that those whose greatest wish
is completely selfless and who then
gained Geass power will have their Geass
power manifest as blue the other big
takeaway that I got from this is that if
Layla's Geass and dashes Geass and the
manga truly allowed them to alter
physical reality that would really
change the stakes and raise the stakes
for Code Geass season 3 if Geass power
can go beyond mental effects and
actually reshape the world itself the
physical world then this has huge
implications for what might happen in
season 3 we might see new more powerful
versions of Geass we might see the
collective consciousness using their
power to alter physical reality
potentially becoming a villain in the
sequel potentially doing other things
that might be interesting and of course
there is also the fact that Lela still
has a valid contract with c2 and she has
this unique Geass power so it is very
possible that all of this might come
into play in season 3 and Lela from
Akito the exiled might return as an
important character in the Code Geass
sequel so what do you guys think you
agree that Blu Geass might indicate
selflessness and that those who have a
selfless desire to only help others or
serve others like orange will have their
Geass manifest as blue also do you
really think that Layla's power is
capable of altering physical reality so
turning back time for example and what
implications do you think that could
have for Code Geass season 3 be sure to
let me know in the comments because I
would love to hear for
and just a quick side note a member of
our discord called Reformation in
progress mentioned that he saw on Reddit
and my anime list articles being posted
or posts being posted on the forums
claiming that the Code Geass PV or
promotional video that leaked onto
YouTube about a few weeks ago is
actually not the full preview that was
shown at the anniversary event for
Cordia the people that have been posting
these messages are claiming that there
is more to the PV that at some point in
the extended preview or extended teaser
trailer you can actually see Lelouch
with blue Geass in one of his eyes now I
don't know if any of this is true it
could be just rumors but if Lelouch
really did have blue Geass in his eye
this could back my selflessness theory
because if Lelouch after choosing to
sacrifice himself at the end of r2 in
order to create a better world so give
up all this power perhaps he was he
thought that he was giving up this life
even if he didn't we don't know if he
was aware that he had code you know
giving up all of his power and we think
that he worked for in order to create a
better world for others perhaps that
selflessness that sacrifice somehow
resulted in his Geass manifesting as
blue again this is just rumors I don't
know if any of this about the little
shoving a blue Geass is true but if he
really did I think that this theory
would make sense anyways thank you guys
so much for watching let me know what
you think down in the comments if you
like these types of videos be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and if you want to
chat with us on a daily basis you can
join our discourse server the link is in
the description and until next time see
ya space cowboys
you
[Applause]
[Music]